the fourth episode of season eight of
Game of Thrones titled the last of the
Starks was a change of pace after last
week's devastating Battle of Winterfell
but it had its fair share of drama
we finally headed back to King's Landing
to see what Cersei and Euron were up to
now that Aria had killed the night king
the battle for the iron throne could
really begin here are 14 details you
might have missed and warning spoilers
are coming each week during season 8
there have been small adjustments made
to the sprawling opening credits we now
see a new damaged Winterfell the insides
of the castle are in shambles as bodies
burn outside the castle walls
as the survivors celebrate and drink
Tyrion Podrick Brienne and Jaime play a
drinking game it's the same drinking
game we've seen several times throughout
the show first in season one with Shae
and bran and another time he tries and
fails to play it with grey worm and Miss
on day anyone not drinking is
disrespecting all Queen if you look
closely you can see Game of Thrones
creators DB Weiss and David Benioff in
the banquet hall you can spot them as
tormund gives his big speech about Jon
meanwhile Arya doesn't join the others
in the banquet hall she's shooting
arrows by herself
Gendry finds her and proposes asking her
to be the lady of storms end
not long after Daenerys declared him
Lord of storms end she says no and tells
him I don't want to be a lady and I'm
not a lady I never have been That's not
me this is a callback to multiple
moments in the show the first is from
season 1 episode 4 cripples bastards and
broken things when Ned talks to her
about her future as a lady and she says
That's not me
there's another callback to this in
season 7 episode 2 Stormborn
when arya tries to get Nymeria to come
back to Winterfell with her when Nymeria
walks away arya realizes her dire wolf
was meant to roam free and she says bran
tells tyrion that his wheelchair is the
same one that Darren Targaryen builds
for his nephew a hundred and twenty
years ago Darren was the eldest son of
king aegon the third in the books Jon
Snow mentions Darren as a sort of
historical hero of his bran tells Tyrion
I've been shoveling Lannister and what
do I have to show Tyrion starts to
respond power resides where men believe
before being cut off this is a callback
to season 2 episode 3 what is dead may
never die Varys says these exact words
to Tyrion power resides where men
believe it resides it's a trick a shadow
on the wall
Arya and the Hound are riding on
horseback to King's Landing The Hound
says I have business left to be done
he's likely referring to killing his
brother the mountain you know is coming
for you you've always known which could
mean that fans might see the
highly-anticipated Clegane ball very
soon
Arya says so do I a reference to her
kill list on which there are technically
just two names left the mountain and
Cersei Daenerys flee is taken by
surprise when you're on in the golden
company shot down Regal there were hints
throughout the episode that the Dragons
were weak if you look closely you can
see that ray galls wings are full of
holes
both Viserion and regal were brought
down in similar ways one by spear and
one by arrow
Euron uses a giant crossbow called the
scorpion which was invented by Qyburn it
was last seen in the season 7 episode
the spoils of war during the loot train
attack bran uses one against drogon he
hits but fails to kill him
this episode also saw the death of
Masson day with her shocking beheading
before Masson day dies Cersei asks her
if she has any last words she chooses
jerk arse the same words Daenerys says
to her dragons before they breathe fire
this is just one of the many clues
throughout the episode that Daenerys is
going mad like her father King Aerys ii
during the banquet torment teases John
and says what kind of person climbs on a
freakin dragon a madman as Daenerys
listens in the background Varys says he
worries about her mental state and now
Masson day is telling her to burn them
all
just like Aerys did
Daenerys says it's her job to bring down
all tyrants and in this case bringing
down a tyrant might involve destroying
an entire city
Cersei gives the order for Masson day's
execution but the mountain swings the
sword in the pilot episode Ned Stark
says the man who passes the sentence
should swing the sword this is not
something the Lannisters do
Joffrey gives the order to someone else
for Ned's head and speaking of Ned Stark
in the first season Cersei tells Ned
when you play the game of Thrones you
win or you die
this explains why Cersei refuses to
surrender for her she either takes the
throne or loses her life during this
episode
both Daenerys and Cersei are seen in
their full house garb Daenerys was
wearing full Targaryen read at the
celebratory feast a nod to her leaning
into the house words of fire and blood
in the final scene of this episode she's
wearing red and white Cersei is also in
full red for the episode just as
Daenerys is embracing her Targaryen
nature Cersei is back to full Lannister
strength lion necklace and all and not
all Easter eggs are intentional someone
seems to have left a coffee cup on the
table and the feast scene
is there anything we missed let us know
in the comments
[Music]